[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग तो सबसे पहले एक
बार आप यह बता दीजिए कि सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है या नहीं दे रही प्लीज बता
दीजिए यस या नो चैट
में
प्लीज बता दीजिए कि यस या नो सबको मेरी
आवाज आ रही है नहीं आ उसके बाद हम अपना
टॉपिक स्टार्ट
करेंगे डोंट वेस्ट अवर
टाइम ओके थैंक यू
टीम तो कोई बात नहीं जो लोग नहीं आए या
कोई भी नहीं आया नो इशू दे रिग्रेट इट
डेफिनेटली आफ्टर सम टाइम तो हम स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं आज डे 14 बेस की जो मास्टरी
क्लास चल रही है और आगे आगे अब धीरे-धीरे
हम इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक्स में जा रहे हैं
इंटरेस्ट आएगा आप लॉजिस लगाने सीखेंगे सब
कुछ सीखेंगे तो लास्ट क्लास में मैंने जो
आपको बताया था वो यूजर से कैसे हमें इनपुट
रिक्वेस्ट करना है उसके बेसिस पर हम कैसे
टास्क परफॉर्म करेंगे वो आगे आगे सीखेंगे
बट हमने यूजर से कैसे इनपुट लेना है एक
इंटरेक्ट वे में भी खास कर के जैसे कि रीड
कमांड के थ्रू या स्लक कमांड के थ्रू
मल्टीपल ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करके जो जनरली आप
अपने टूल्स में यूज करते हैं वो
सब वो सब इधर क्या है हम सीखने सीख चुके
हैं तो उसके बेसिस पर दो दो प्रोजेक्ट दिए
थे मैंने आप लोगों को लास्ट क्लासेस में
तो वोह दो प्रोजेक्ट मुझे लगता नहीं किसी
ने किए होंगे तो इट्स ओके मैं उसको एंड ऑफ
द दिस क्लास मैं उसको उनमें से एक
प्रोजेक्ट को डिस्कस करूंगा असाइनमेंट को
डिस्कस करूंगा काफी इजी असाइनमेंट है और
जिससे आपका क्या है हैंड्स ऑन हो जाएगा कि
स्मल हैंड्स ऑन की पर्टिकुलर कमांड्स के
ऊपर कि कैसे उसके ऊपर अपने कोड लिख सकता
हूं तो सॉरी फॉर दैट की अबकी बाद जो क्लास
है आपकी डिले आई उसका रीजन यही है कि अबकी
बार मैं थोड़ा अवेलेबल नहीं था थोड़े आपकी
सर अवेलेबल नहीं थे तो हमारा थोड़ा सा
कॉमिनेशन हो नहीं पाया कभी वे नहीं थे कभी
मैं फरीना तो ट्स वाई आई एम सॉरी फॉर ट तो
आज हम सीखने वाले हैं लॉजिक सेक्शन है जो
हमारा उसके अंदर जाने वाले हैं कि लॉजिस
कैसे लगाएंगे लॉजिस इन द सेंस की हम इफ
कमांड कैसे यूज करेंगे देन उसके बाद हम फ
के फर लूप वाय लूप के बारे में पढ़ेंगे
लेकिन लॉजिक सेक्शन से इफ कमांड से पहले
कुछ उसके भी कुछ चीजें हैं जो बेसिक चीजें
हैं जो आपको मैं बताने वाला हूं और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग है आपको मजा आएगा तो चलिए हम
अपनी स्क्रीन नोट्स में चलते हैं और
स्टार्ट करते
हैं चलो इसको डिस्कस करते हैं बाद में जो
आज का हमारा टॉपिक है ना सबसे पहले हम बात
करने वाले हैं सबसे पहले जो हमारा टॉपिक
है शायद मुझे सब सबको ये स्क्रीन पर
क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा होगा मुझे इससे
ज्यादा और जूम करने की जरूरत ना पड़े ये
रहा ये रहा आई थिंक ये रहा ये रहा तो हाउ
टू मेक चेंज ऑफ कमांड्स विद लिस्ट
ऑपरेटर तो अब ये लिस्ट ऑपरेटर क्या होता
है और चेंज ऑफ कमांड्स क्या होता है देखो
जितना भी मैं बेस स्क्रिप्टिंग आपको पढ़ा
रहा हूं टेक्निकल वे में पढ़ा रहा हूं ऐसे
ही नहीं कि बाकी की तरह कि मैं बस सिंपली
कमांड्स बता दिया नहीं टेक्निकल जो वर्ड्स
है उनको मैं यूज कर रहा हूं एक्चुअल में
अगर आप लोगों को यकीन नहीं है तो मैं आपको
जब बेस की मैनुअल प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा जो जो
ऑनलाइन अवेलेबल है उसमें देख लीजिए वो
सारी चीजें उसी में से ही है कुछ भी मैं
अपने पास से नहीं बता रहा हूं ना खुद से
मैंने कुछ बनाया है तो अब सबसे पहले बात
करते हैं चेंस ऑफ कमांड का मतलब क्या है
चेंस ऑफ कमांड क्या होती है जब भी किसी भी
कमांड लाइन के अंदर हम जब एक या एक से
ज्यादा कमांड्स को फायर करते हैं एक या एक
से कमांड को एक या एक से ज्यादा कमांड को
रन करते हैं तो वो क्या करती है एक चेन बन
जाती है कमांड्स की उसको हम बोलते हैं
चेंस ऑफ कमांड ओके विद और जो चेंज ऑफ
कमांड है यह पॉसिबल हो पाती है लिस्ट
ऑपरेटर की हेल्प से और लिस्ट ऑपरेटर क्या
होते हैं लिस्ट ऑपरेटर आर नथिंग जस्ट टाइप
ऑफ कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स यह भी एक प्रकार के
कंट्रोल ऑपरेटर्स ही है और लिस्ट ऑपरेटर्स
कौन कन से होते हैं
बेसिकली ए परट डबल एम परसेंट सेमीकलन और
पाइप सिंबल जो आपको स्क्रीन पर देखने को
मिल रहे होंगे अब जो एम पर है इसका मतलब
क्या होता है जो ऑपरेटर अलाउ यू टू रन
कमांड ए
सिंक्रोनस इसका मतलब क्या होता है कि आप
क्या करते हो कि कुछ ऐसे टास्क या ऐसी
प्रोसेस आप अपने टर्मिनल में या अपने
कमांड में रन करना जा रहे जो काफी टाइम
कंजूमिंग है जो क्या करेगी टाइम लेगी
कंप्लीट होने में बट क्या है कि आप नहीं
चाहते कि उसकी वजह से आपका काम रुके या
फरदर कोई नया टास्क परफॉर्म करना है नई
प्रोसेस रन करनी है या कोई नई कमांड रन
करनी है आपको कम सेल में लेकिन आप नहीं
चाहते कि मैं उसके लिए वेट करूं मैं नहीं
चाहता कि मैं वेट करना करना पसंद करूंगा
तो उस केस में हम क्या करते हैं एमसेंट
ऑपरेटर का यूज करते हैं यह क्या करता है
आपकी जो कमांड है उसको बैकग्राउंड में रन
कर देता है उसको एक जॉब नंबर साइन कर देता
है और जब वो कंप्लीट हो जाती है तो उसको
अनोलेट भी कर देता है आपको कई बार आपको
देखने को मिला है अगर शॉर्ट टाइम में अगर
वो कंप्लीट हो जाती तो क्या है
एक्नॉलेजमेंट भी उसका दे देता है आपको बता
देता है कंप्लीट
बाकी तो ये था आपका एम परसेंट का मतलब अब
बात करते हैं डबल एम परसेंट
ऑपरेटर जो डबल एम परट ऑपरेटर होता है उसको
हम बोल सकते हैं एंड ऑपरेटर उसको हम बोलते
हैं एंड ऑपरेटर अब इसका मतलब क्या है कि
इसमें क्या करते हो आप दो कमांड देते हो
क्योंकि सीधी सी बात है कि हम मल्टीपल
कमांड के यूज कर रहे हैं तो सिंपल मतलब यह
है एंड ऑपरेटर का बेसिकली वही काम होता है
नॉर्मली जो एंड काम करता है यहां पर जब
क्या करते हैं कि सेकंड कमांड रन तभी
करेगी जब पहली कमांड सक्सेसफुल होगी मतलब
सक्सेसफुल रन करेगी या ट्रू होगी तभी
सेकंड कमांड आपकी रन करेगी अब बात करते
हैं और की इससे पहले मैं और की बता देता
हूं डबल पाइप सिंबल जो आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है इसका मतलब क्या है द ओर ऑपरेटर मीन
सेकंड कमांड ओनली रन इफ द फर्स्ट वन फेल्ड
देखो इनम डिफरेंस ही है कि जो डबल एम पर
जो एंड ऑपरेटर है सेकंड कमांड उसमें तभी
रन करेगी जब फर्स्ट कमांड सक्सेसफुल होगी
और उसी के बेसिस पर आपका आउटपुट आएगा या
उसी के बेसिस पर आपको कोई भी कंडीशन होगी
वह रन करेगी लेकिन जो और ऑपरेटर है जिसमें
डबल पाइप आपको देख रहे फोर्थ नंबर पर उसकी
जो सेकंड नंबर कमांड होगी वो तभी रन करेगी
जब उसकी पहली कमांड फॉल्स होगी या गलत
होगी फेल होगी तभी वो कमांड रन करेगी और
उसका आउटपुट आपको आपकी स्क्रीन पर देखने
को मिलेगा ओनली सेकंड कमांड का अदर वाइज
फर्स्ट ट्रू होगी तो सेकंड कमांड रन ही
नहीं करेगी और ऑपरेटर के केस में अब बात
करते हैं सेमी कलन ऑपरेटर अब सेमी कलन जो
ऑपरेटर है वो क्या करता है आपकी कमांड को
सीक्वेंस रन करता है वन आफ्टर अनदर इट डजन
मैटर कि फर्स्ट कमांड
सक्सेसफुल और
नॉट मतलब सिंपल यही है कि पहली कमांड
सक्सेस हुई या व फेल हुई से कोई मतलब नहीं
यह सेकंड कमांड को रन करेगा ही करेगा मतलब
य डिपेंडेंट नहीं है एंड की तरह और और की
तरह यह सेकंड कमांड को रन करेगा अगर
फर्स्ट में एरर तो एरर के साथ उसका आट शो
करेगा लेकिन क्या है कि य सीक्वेंस
सीक्वेंस एक के बाद दो दो के बाद तीन तीन
के बाद चार ऐसे ही में ये काम करेगा तो यह
थे आपके लिस्ट ऑफ ऑपरेटर्स जिनके बारे में
हम क्या प्रैक्टिकली सीखेंगे अभी कि
प्रैक्टिकली कैसे इसके बारे में हम करेंगे
तो हम मैं चलता हूं अपने मशीन मशीन पर हम
टर्मिनल पर चलते हैं एक बार मैं आपको जूम
कर देता हूं य आपको देखने को मिलेगा
जूम
आई होप की ये काफी है जूम लेवल आपके लिए
तो सबसे पहले बात करते हैं हम एंड ऑपरेटर
की तो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं एकको करता हूं और
मैंने क्या किया को और मैंने टूथ और एंड
मैंने यूज किया ए पर सिंपली उसके बाद किया
मैंने एकको और 89 जीरो कर दिया और हिट
एंटर किया अब देखो पहली कमांड को जो एक
टूथ उसको क्या कर दिया ने बैकग्राउंड में
रन किया उसको एक जॉब नंबर साइन कर दिया
उसके बाद जो एकको 890 है उसको उसका आउटपुट
शो कर दिया देन उसके बाद टूथ का भी इस
क्योंकि पहली वाली कमांड कंप्लीट हो गई डन
आपके सामने उसने आपका आउटपुट भी शो कर
दिया मतलब क्या किया इसने यह भी बता दिया
कि आपकी जो नोटिफाई कर दिया आपको कि जो
आपने बैकग्राउंड में जो जॉब रन की थी वह
भी कंप्लीट हो गई है इस तरीके से m पर का
काम करते हैं और बेसिकली आप कई बार कहां
यूज कर करते हो कई बार जब आप क्या करते हो
जब आप शाय अपनी पन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होते
हैं तो कुछ टूल्स होते हैं जो अ जैसे कि
ओपन वीपीएन यूज़ करते हैं तो ओपन वीपीएन
का जब टर्मिनल पर एक बना फायर कर दिया तो
उसके बाद क्या कंटिन्यू स्क्रीन रन करती
रहती है अब क्या करते है कि भैया उसके लिए
फिर आपने क्या करता है नया टर्मिनल ओपन
करता है उसके बाद अपनी कमांड्स को यूज
करते हैं तो उसके लिए हम क्या कर दो
सिंपली ओपन वीपीएन को बैकग्राउंड में डाल
दो तो बैकग्राउंड में चलता रहेगा और उससे
आपका दूसरी कमांड रन करने में आपको कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं होगी फिर वो अपना
बैकग्राउंड में काम करता रहेगा जब आपको
उसको किल करना तो फोरग्राउंड में लेके आइए
उसको स्विच कीजिए फोरग्राउंड उसके बाद किल
कर दीजिए सिंपल मल्टीपल टर्मिनल ओपन करने
की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी आपको अब बात करते
हैं कि जो आपका सेमीकलन ऑपरेटर वो कैसे
काम करता मैंने क्या किया एकको किया और अब
क्या टूथ और उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया
सेमीकलन देन एकको ये सीक्वेंस रन करेगा 4
फ 56 से कर दिया मैंने हिट एंटर देखो ट 3
5 6 से पहले टूथ रन करेगी उसके बाद 5 स से
रन करेगी ओके अगर मैं डज टर की पहली फेल
हुई पास हुई सक्सेस हुई नहीं हुई उससे कोई
मतलब नहीं इसको यह क्या करेगा य रन करेगा
ही करेगा इस तरीके से क्या करती है आपकी
आपकी जो सेमी कोलन ऑपरेटर है काम करता
है अब बात करते हैं डबल एम परसेंट ऑपरेटर
की ड ए परट का मतलब क्या करते हैं कि अगर
फर्स्ट कमांड ट्रू होगी या फर्स्ट कमांड
सक्सेसफुली रन होगी तब भी सेकंड कमांड रन
करेगी मैंने एकको किया उसके बाद टूथ किया
डबल ए परसेंट देन एकको किया देन फर 567 कर
दिया टटर अभी दोनों रन कर दिया अगर मैं
क्या करता हूं कि मैंने क्या किया एलस अभी
दिखाता हूं एलस कुछ भी लिख दिया ये देन
उसके बाद डबल ए परसेंट देन एकको कर दिया
एकको टूथ अब देखो एलस कैन नोट एक्सेस नो
सच फाइल डायरेक्ट टूथ रन ही नहीं गया
क्योंकि जो आपकी पहली कमांड थी एलएस वाली
यह सक्सेसफुली रन नहीं हुई ये इसके ऊपर
डिपेंडेंट थी सेकंड कमांड इसलिए इस पर कुछ
भी काम नहीं किया अब बात करते इसके केस
में अगर एलस किया सेम कमांड और इसकी यूज
करता हूं पाइप सिंबल और ऑपरेटर डबल यह रहा
पाइप सिम डबल पाइप किया मैंने और हिट एंटर
कर दिया अब देखो आपको जो आउटपुट है एकको
123 ये टूथ आपका आउटपुट देखने को मिल रहा
है अगर फर्स्ट कमांड आपकी सक्सेसफुली रन
भी नहीं करी तो तब ये क्या तब भी आपकी
सेकंड कमांड रन करेगी उसका आउटपुट आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है यही है वो मेजर
डिफरेंस दोनों के बीच में कि उसमें वो
डिपेंडेंट है फर्स्ट कमांड के ऊपर ये भी
डिपेंडेंट है बट क्या है कि फर्स्ट कमांड
रन करेगी तो सेकंड करेगी इसमें क्या है
सेकंड कमांड तभी रन करे जब फर्स्ट कमांड
फेल होगी और ऑपरेटर में तो इस तरीके से
आपको मैं शो कर दिया आप इनको एक काम कर
सकते हो कि मिक्स तरीके से यूज कर सकते हो
नॉर्मली हम क्या करते हैं जब स्क्रिप्टिंग
करते हैं प्रोग्रामिंग करते हैं तो हम
क्या करते हैं मिक्स यूज करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं कैसे मिक्स कर सकते हैं हम
मैं इसको आपको दिखाता हूं यहां पर लिखूंगा
कमांड कमांड ए लिखा देन मैसे यूज कर सकता
हूं डबल एम परट कमांड बी उसके बाद
सो सीओ ड एम ए एनडी कमांड बी उसके बाद मैं
सेसे यूज कर सकता हूं डबल पाइप सिंबल और
कमांड सी टटर अभी तो कुछ नहीं आएगा बट
क्या है इस तरीके से कमांड ए नॉट फाउंड
कमांड सी नॉट फाउंड सिंपली इस तरीके से
मल्टीपल तरीके से भी आप यूज कर सकते हो
कैसे मैंने क्या किया
एक वन थ 4 किया मैंने उसके बाद डबल एम परट
उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया एकको उसके बाद
678 कर दिया देन डेबल अब ये देखना
डिपेंडेंट अब आप लोग ही सोचना अब फिर से
मैंने क्या किया एक को और ई आर ए य आर अभी
बताइए क्या आउटपुट आना चाहिए क्योंकि देखो
ये ट्रू है तो ये रन करेगी ये भी ट्रू अब
ये दोनों ट्रू है तो इसका मतलब ये रन नहीं
करेगी हिट एंटर देखिए हिट एंटर अब उनमें
से एक भी कमांड अगर गलत है और एग्जांपल एक
भी कमांड अगर गलत है मैंने क्या किया एलएस
ये रहा देन हिट एंटर अभी देखो ई आर
क्योंकि इनमें से ये गलत है सेकंड क रन
नहीं करेगी तो पूरा फाल्स हो गया मतलब
पूरी फेल होगी यह वाली फेल होगी तो इसका
जो आउटपुट है एकको ई आरफ यह वाला आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है तो यह था
आपका कौन सा मल्टीपल कमांड को एक साथ कैसे
यूज करना है यह था आपका मल्टीपल कमांड को
एक साथ कैसे यूज करते हाउ टू मेक चेंज ऑफ
कमांड विद लिस्ट ऑपरेटर्स ये चारों लिस्ट
ऑपरेटर्स मैंने आपको बता दिया है
प्रैक्टिकली आपको दिखा दिया है उसके बाद
आपको चेनिंग ऑफ कमांड कैसे बनानी है आपको
पता चल गया होगा इनको आपस में मिक्स करके
भी यूज कर सकते हैं नॉर्मली आप क्या
स्क्रिप्ट में यूज भी करते हैं तो अब जो
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक हमारा वह हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
वह आपका टेस्ट कमांड के बारे में जो
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक आपको स्क्रीन पर देखने को
मिल रहा है वो हमारा है टेस्ट कमांड के
बारे में अब भैया बोलो टेस्ट कमांड होती
क्या है सिंपली देखो यह कमांड बेसिकली
आपके लॉजिकल चेक्स करने के लिए यूज जाती
है जब भी आप क्या करते हो कि इफ कंडीशन
यूज करते हो या इवन वाइल लूप भी यूज करते
तो वो क्या करते हैं वो किसी ना किसी
कंडीशन के बेस प ही रन करते हैं वो कंडीशन
ट्रू या फाल्स होगी तभी उसी के बेसिस पर
आप क्या करते हैं कोई भी कोड रन करवाते
हैं कोई भी आउटपुट लेते हैं या कोई भी
उसके बेसिस पर फंक्शन कुछ भी रन करवाते
हैं बेसिकली आप लॉजिक उसी के बेस पर लगाते
हो किसी भी तो बेस में यह लॉजिक देखने के
लिए लॉजिक चेक करने के लिए एक कमांड का
यूज किया जाता है वो होती है टेस्ट कमांड
तो टेस्ट कमांड इज ए कमांड दैट कैन बी
यूज्ड इन बैस टू कंपेयर डिफरेंट पीसेज ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन अगर मुझे किसी भी इंफॉर्मेशन
को कंपेयर करना है और उसके बेसिस पर अगर
मुझे अपना आउटपुट चाहिए तो मुझे टेस्ट
कमांड का यूज करना ही पड़ेगा उसके बिना
मैं इफ कमांड को या किसी भी कमांड को यूज
नहीं कर सकता क् विदाउट लॉजिस हम
प्रोग्रामिंग करते ही नहीं ही है इफ ए
टेस्ट इज एलिवेटेड टू बी ट्रू देन इट विल
रिटर्न एन एजि स्टेटस ऑफ जीरो मतलब अगर
आपने जो लॉजिक लगाया अगर वो लॉजिक ट्रू है
तो उसका जो ये क्या करता है उसका जो एजि
स्टेटस है उसको जीरो रिटर्न करता है और
आपको पता है कि जितना भी सक्सेस और
अनसक्सेस का काम आपकी बैस के अंदर ऑन द
बेसिस ऑफ एग्जिट स्टेटस कोड जो एग्जिट
स्टेटस कोड है उसी के आधार पर ही सारे काम
होते हैं किय सक्सेस हुआ या फेल हुआ अगर
जो लॉजिक आपने लगाया वह है फाल्स तो उसका
जो एग्जिट स्टेटस कोड आपको देखने को
मिलेगा वो वन मिलेगा अभी कोई भाई पुरानी
किसी भी लैंग्वेज को सीख के आया होगा तो
थोड़ा सा कंफ्यूज हो गया होगा कि वहां पर
उल्टा होता है कि अगर ट्रू है तो स्टेटस
कोड वन होता है फाल्स है तो जीरो होता है
लेकिन बैस में ऐसा नहीं होता बैस में अगर
ट्रू है तो उसका ए स्टेटस जीरो होगा और
अगर वो फाल्स है तो उसका एक स्टेटस वन
होगा अब जो इसका सिंटेक्स है वो सिंटेक्स
होता आपका यह रहा आपको स्क्रीन के सामने
सिंटेक्स आपके स्क्रीन के सामने है यह
रहा डबल ओपन एंड क्लोज ब्रैकेट्स होते हैं
स्क्वेयर ब्रैकेट्स ओके अब इस स्क्वेयर
ब्रैकेट के अंदर ही आप क्या करते हो अपने
टेस्ट लिखते हो या लॉजिस लिखते हो जिनको
आप कंपेयर करना चाहते हो या वो इंफॉर्मेशन
लिखते हो जो आप कंपेयर करना चाहते हो
सिंपली मैंने आपको एरो डाउन करके खा हुआ
है इनसाइड द स्क्वेयर ब्रैकेट यू राइट योर
टेस्ट या यू राइट योर स्क्रिप्ट सिंपल ये
है उसके बाद नोट ऑलवेज रिमेंबर टू पुट
स्पेस आफ्टर द ओपनिंग ब्रैकेट एंड बिफोर द
क्लोजिंग ब्रैकेट
मेरे कहने का मतलब यहां पर क्या है कि
यहां पर एक चीज ध्यान में रखनी है इसलिए
मैंने एरो डाउन किया है बिल्कुल सेंटर में
जब आप ब्रैकेट ओपन कर रहे हो तब आपको एक
स्पेस देना है और जब आप ब्रैकेट क्लोज कर
रहे हो तब आपको स्पेस देना है और उसके बीच
में ही आपको क्या करने है अपने लॉजिस
परफॉर्म करने हैं या अपने वोह लॉजिस यूज
करने हैं जो आप परफॉर्म करवाना चाहते हो
अदर वाइज अगर आप एक ये स्पेस वाला जो सीन
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं जो कंडीशन बता रहा
हूं अगर आप उसको यूज नहीं कर करने वाले तो
आपको वहां पर सिंटेक्स एरर देखने को मिल
सकती है कोई भी सिंटेक्स एरर आपको वहां पर
देखने को मिल सकती है तो यह है वो आपको
देखने को मिल रहा होगा यह इसका सिंटेक्स
है तो करली ब्रैकेट्स ओपन कर उसके बाद
आपको क्या है स्पेस देना है ओपन करने के
बाद और क्लोज करने से पहले और इसके बीच
में जहां पर मैंने एरो दिखाया है ये
इसीलिए दिखाया ताकि आपको क्लियर हो जाए अब
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं प्रैक्टिकली आप इसको
कैसे कुछ भी टेस्ट चेक कर सकते हो उसके
बाद चलते हैं हम अपने टर्मिनल के के ऊपर
स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर लेता हूं देन अब फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं एक बार क्या करता हूं इंटी
जर के बेसिस पर कुछ टेस्ट करना चाहता हूं
तो उसके लिए आपको क्या करना पहले मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं ये रहा स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट ओपन
स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट क्लोज उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है एक स्पेस यहां देना है
देन उसके बाद स्पेस देना है उसके बाद एक
और स्पेस दो स्पेस मेंशन कर दो देन ये
रहा एको स्पेस अब यहां पर आपको क्या करनी
है आपकी कंडीशन लिखनी है फॉर एग्जांपल मैं
लिखता हूं टू देन हाइन e क इक्वल e क2 आन
e क2 अभी ये क्या बोल रहा है वैसे इनके ये
रहा कि मैं ये चेक करना चा कि ू हान क
मतलब इक्वल 2 इक्ट क्या ये ट्रू है या
फाल्स है ये कंडीशन चेक करना है यहां पर
आपको क्या करना है जब आपकी एक बार कंडीशन
क्या होगी जो आपका लॉजिकल लॉजिक खत्म हो
गया कंपेरिजन जो करना है उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है से कॉलन दे देना है देन आप
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं यहां पर अभी ये यहां
वो टेस्ट कोड के अंदर देना है बट इधर मैं
रेमी कॉलन इसलिए दे रहा हूं ताकि नेक्स्ट
कमांड में रन कर सकूं फिर मैं अगर मैं
एकको करता हूं और डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क
करता हूं आपको पता है डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क
क्या करता है एजि स्टेटस कोड दिखाता है तो
इसका एजि स्टेटस कोड क्या आया जीरो इसका
मतलब ये जो कंडीशंस है ये टेस्ट है पास हो
गया ये एक ट्रू टेस्ट है देन अगर मैं क्या
करता हूं फिर से एक और टेस्ट पास करता हूं
देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं वन आन
इक्वल मतलब न इक्वल
टूट उसके बाद देन उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
एक उसके बाद डॉलर और क्वेश्चन मार्क देन ट
अब अननोन कंडीशन आईन इक्वल उसके बाद
टू ओके ओके व्ट
हैपन
ओके ओके e क है क है सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी फॉर ट
e क देन ये रहा यहां पर स्ट आपको क्या
देखने को मिल रहा है वन इसका ए स्टेटस कोड
आपको क्या देखने को मिल रहा है वन तो हाइन
e क होता है इक्वल अब अगर मैं ऐसा करता
हूं फॉर एग्जांपल ये यहां पर न e की ज आप
क्या क सकते हो ए क नॉट इक्वल हाफ नॉट
इक्वल तो इसका स्टेटस कोड
ए इक्वल नॉट ई एन क नहीं एनई एन एनई एन
ओके ए होता है ये रहा नॉट इक्वल ये होता
है नॉट इक्वल तो न नॉट इक्वल टूटू य ट्रू
कंडीशन इसका स्टेटस आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है इस प्रकार से आपको अगर लिस्ट करके
दिखाता हूं आपकी स्क्रीन पर अगर आपको यह
ये रहा चलते हैं ये रहा इधर मैं आपको एक
काम कर देता हूं यह रहा कुछ टेस्ट कंडीशन
लिख दिखा देता हूं क्या होता है देखो
हाइन ई क होता है आपका हान क होता है आपका
इक्वल यू एल इक्वल होता है देन हाइन एनई
होता है वो आपका होता
है नॉट इक्वल ई क य ए नॉट
इक्वल य होता आपका नॉट इक्वल देन उसके बाद
जो आपका
हाइन जीटी होता है वो होता है आपका ग्रेटर
दन वो आपका होता है ग्रेटर देन आर ई एटी
ग्रेटर देन ग्रेटर देन के लिए यूज करते
हैं हाइन अगर हम एलटी लिखते हैं तो हम
इसको लिखते हैं हाइन एलटी ये होता है लेस
देन लेस देन हाइन एलटी अगर मैं यहां पर
हाइन जी क करता हूं तो ग्रेटर दन इक्वल टू
इसका मतलब होता है ग्रेटर
देन इक्वल टू इसका मतलब होता है ग्रेटर
देन इक्वल टू अगर मैं यहां पर मेंशन करता
हूं हाइन हाइन एई क इसका मतलब होता है लेस
देन और लेस देन इक्वल टू लेस देन इक्वल टू
e क य ए एल इक्वल टू इसका मतलब होता है
लेस दन इक्वल टू ये आपका क्या है इंटी जर
के बेसिस पर अगर आपको अपनी वैल्यू को चेक
करना है तो इस तरीके से कर सकते हो और ये
ओनली इंटी जर के लिए काम करता है डेसीमल
वैल्यू के लिए काम नहीं करता ये चीज आपको
ध्यान में रखनी है अब बात करते हैं हम
स्ट्रिंग टेस्ट कैसे करना है य तो इंटी जर
टेस्ट था अब मैं बात करते हैं स्ट्रिंग
टेस्ट कैसे करते हैं स्ट्रिंग टेस्ट करने
के स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं देन मैं
चलता हूं अभी फॉपल ने ए वेरिएबल ए के अंदर
मैंने मेंशन किया हेलो देन एक बी वेरिएबल
है बी के अंदर वैल्यू स्टोर की मैंने वो
वैल्यू की मैंने गुड हेलो
गुड गुड बाय गुड बाय हिट एंटर देन अब मैं
क्या करता हूं अभी इसको क्या करता हूं अभी
इसको कंपेरिजन करता हूं इसका मैं क्या
करूंगा
कंपैरिजन करूंगा
कंपेरिजन कैसे करूंगा
की य ओपन ओपन और क्लोज ब्रैकेट देन यूज कर
रहा
हूं डॉलर ए देन इक्वल सिंबल देन डॉलर बी
उसके बाद स्पेस उसके बाद यह रहा देन मैं
क्या करता हूं एक
और डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क डलर क्वे मार्क ट
एटर अभय क्या ए इ बी है नहीं है ए इ बी
नहीं है इसलिए क्या कर दिया इसको वन शो कर
दिया अगर मैं क्या करता हूं कि जो दोनों
वैल्यू गुड बाय इसको मैं क्या करता हूं
हेलो कर देता हूं इसके अंदर भी मैं हेलो
लिख देता हूं
हेलो हिट एंटर देन मैं क्या करता हूं ए इ
बी है यस जीरो ए इ बी है अगर नॉट इक्वल
नॉट इक्वल चेक करना है न इल टू बी है तो य
पर सिंपल ये सिंबल यूज करोगे नॉट इक्वल टू
है अरे ऐसा नहीं भैया हां नॉट इक्वल टू बी
है इट एंटर यस ये नॉट इक्वल टू बी है
सिंबल आपको यूज करना है ये ऑटोमेटिक इसमें
कन्वर्ट कर दे रहा है तो ये क्या है बेस
बेस नहीं है ना इसलिए ज चल रहा है तो इस
तरीके से आप स्ट्रिंग भी चेक कर सकते हो
इक्वल है या नॉट इक्वल टू है कोई भी
स्ट्रिंग टेस्ट ऑपरेटर में जब बात खास
करके वेरिएबल के अंदर की वैल्यू की बात कर
रहे हो अब और भी होते है स्ट्रिंग टेस्ट
में एक हाइन जड ऑपरेटर होता है इसके अंदर
हाइन जड होता है हान जड क्या करता है कि
आप ये चेक कर दो कि जो म स्ट्रिंग है वो
एमटी है या नहीं है कैसे चेक करना है ये
रहा ओपन ब्रैकेट क्लोज ब्रैकेट देन एकको
स्पेस एकको स्पेस देन एको स्पेस इसके बीच
में लिखते हैं मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर
हाइन जड हान जड का मतलब होता है आपको ये
चेक करना कि स्ट्रिंग एमटी है यानी हान जड
और मैं लिखा डॉलर सी डॉलर सी तो कोई भी
मेरा वेरिएबल नहीं है ना कुछ नहीं है हिट
एंटर किया उसके एंटर के बज मैं एकको और
डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क क्वेश्चन मार्क ट
एंटर किया अब ये दिखा रहा जो जीरो क्यों
जीरो क्यों दिखा रहा है क्यों कि ये एमटी
है अगर मैं इसकी एमटी है अगर मैं इसको
क्या कर देता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल वो कर देता
हूं ये रहा सी की जगह मैं लिखता हूं बी
क्या ये एमटी है हिट एंटर ये वन दिखा रहा
है फॉल्स दिखा रहा है क्योंकि एमटी नहीं
है क्योंकि उसके अंदर कोई ना कोई वैल्यू
है इस तरीके से ये भी चेक कर सकते हो कि
ये जो मेरी स्ट्रिंग है ये एमटी है या जो
मेरा वेरिएबल है ये एमटी है य इसके अंदर
या नल स्ट्रिंग है या नहीं है यह सब हम
चेक कर सकते हैं विद द हेल्प ऑफ हाइन जड
ऑपरेटर की हेल्प से स्ट्रिंग के केस में
और एक और होता है हाइन जड की जगह हाइन n
यूज करोगे हाइन ए का मतलब अपोजिट ऑफ जड
हाइन ए अपोजिट ऑफ जन मतलब ये नॉन एमटी है
यस जीरो आना चाहिए क्योंकि ये नॉन एमटी है
इसलिए आपको जीरो देखने को मिल रहा है ये
क्या है नॉन एमटी है इसलिए यहां पर जीरो
देखने को मिल रहा है अगर मैं इसको दूसरे
केस में यूज करूं य पर ये रहा सी सी तो
मेरा एमटी है स की जगह सी मेरा एमटी है तो
यहां पर मैं हान ए यूज करता हूं तो ये रहा
हिट एंटर तो आपको देख जीरो क्योंकि ये हान
ए मतलब नॉन एमटी है ओके व्हाट इ द
इशू स कोई असाइन नहीं है ना एक्चुअल में
मैं और वैल्यू लेता हूं ओपन ब्रैकेट न n
उसके बाद नॉट इक्वल टू मतलब न नॉन एमटी
डॉलर डी इसको करता हूं उसके बाद क्लोज
उसके बाद देन एकको उसके बाद डॉलर इससे हम
चेक कर पा रहे स्टेटस कोड क्या है डॉलर
क्वेश्चन मार्क ट एटर अभी भी जीरो दिखा
रहा है नॉन एमटी आई डोंट व्हाट इज द इशू
बिकॉज ऑफ दिस इज नॉट द बेस्ट तो ये इशू भी
हो सकता है तो उसका मतलब क्या है नॉन एमटी
स्ट्रिंग चेक करने के लिए आप यूज कर रहे
हो नॉन एमटी अब बात करते हैं ये तो आपका
केस था आपका स्ट्रिंग टेस्ट का स्ट्रिंग
टेस्ट में मैंने आपको क्या वैसे बहुत सारे
होते हैं ये अकेला यह नहीं है मैं आई विल
ट्राई टू प्रोवाइड यू बेस मैनुअल जो
अवेलेबल है ऑनलाइन उसमें बहुत सारे लिखे
हुए हैं खास करके इसी पेज के साथ तो
नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं कि जो है
आपका फाइल टेस्ट कैसे करते हैं फाइल टेस्ट
ऑपरेटर कैसे कर स फॉर एग्जांपल मैं चेक
करना चाहता हूं कि यह फाइल मेरी एजिस्ट
करती भी है या नहीं है यह चेक करने के लिए
मैं क्या करता हूं न ब्रैकेट क्लोज
ब्रैकेट देन उसके बाद एक स्पेस दो स्पेस
ये हो गया इसके बाद मैं क्या कर इसके अंदर
लिखता हूं अपनी लॉजिक लॉजिक हाइन ई यूज
करते हैं हम हान e हम क्या करते हैं चेक
करने के लिए कि ये पर्टिकुलर फाइल एजिस्ट
करती भी है या नहीं है तो मैंने लिखा टू
डे डेड t एकटी क्या ये फाइल मेरी एजिस्ट
करती भी है या नहीं देन उसके बाद एक किया
और डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क ए यस वन मतलब ये
मेरी फाइल एजिस्ट नहीं करती एजिस्ट करती
होती तो जीरो आता यहां पर वन आया इसलिए
फाइल एजिस्ट नहीं करते मैं क्या करता हूं
टच करता हूं उसके बाद क्या टुडे डटी एकटी
फाइल मैं क्या करता हूं क्रिएट कर देता
हूं देन मैं इस लॉजिक को फिर से चेक करता
हूं न e डेड एक्टी अबकी बार ये आया जीरो
दिखा रहा है मतलब डेड एक्टी फाइल में
सिस्टम में क्या करती है एजिस्ट करती है
तो इस तरीके से मैं यह भी चेक कर सकता हूं
कि मैं सिस्टम में जो फाइल है वो एजिस्ट
करती है या नहीं
है अगर मैं चाहूं तो यह भी चेक कर सकता
हूं कि जो पर्टिकुलर फाइल है ये एक रेगुलर
फाइल है या कोई टेक्स्ट फाइल है या वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट है या कोई पीडीएफ है यह भी चेक
कर सकता हूं उसके लिए एक ऑपरेटर होता है
उसका नाम है हान f उसके लिए होता है न f
यहां पर यूज कर सकते हैं न f की to.txt
मेरी एक रेगुलर फाइल है ये एक पीडीएफ है
डॉक्यूमेंट है इनमें से है तो ये इसका
स्टेटस को ये यस जीरो मतलब क्योंकि एक
टेक्स्ट फाइल है आपको नहीं पता च तो देखो
फाइल उसके बाद डेड t एकटी आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है इसका फाइल टाइ क्या है एमटी है
वैसे भी डे तो नॉर्मल एक टी एक्सटी फाइल
ही है डॉक्यूमेंट फाइल है अगर आप चाहो तो
यह भी चेक कर सकते हो क्या यय डायरेक्टरी
है क्या ये चेक कर सकते कि ये जो
पर्टिकुलर नाम डायरेक्टरी है या नहीं है
तो ये हान इसके लिए यूज करूंगा हान डी हिट
एंटर तो शो करे कि भैया यह डायरेक्टरी
नहीं है आप यह फाल्स है तो मैं भी चेक कर
सकता हूं पर्टिकुलर जो नाम आपने दिया या
जो चीज आप फाइंड आउट करने की कोश कर रहे
हो क्या कोई डायरेक्टरी है या नहीं है
उसके बाद हम इसमें और फर्द यूजफुल ऑपरेटर
यूज करते हैं वो एक मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
यूजफुल ऑपरेटर है कि वो होता है आपका हान
x इट इज यूज्ड टू टेस्ट इफ ए फाइल एजिस्ट
एंड हैज एग्जीक्यूशन परमिशन मतलब सिंपली
ये है कि अगर मैं हान x ऑपरेटर का यूज
करता हूं इसी के अंदर तो सबसे पहले तो चेक
चेक करता है कि ये फाइल एजिस्ट करती है या
नहीं है अगर फाइल एजिस्ट करती है तो उसके
ऊपर यह चेक करता है कि ये एग्जीक्यूशन
परमिशन है या नहीं है बेसिकली हम क्या
करते हैं इसको डिजाइन किया गया है
स्क्रिप्ट के लिए यह खास कर की काफी हैंडी
होती है जब आप स्क्रिप्ट लिख रहे होते हैं
कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट रन कर रहे होते हैं या
किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट को चेक करने के लिए कि
इस पे एग्जीक्यूशन परमिश है या नहीं है तो
कैसे हम यूज कर सकते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने एक किया टीय सी एच टच एक फाइल का
नाम लिखा
मैंने
डेमो डेमो लिखा हिट एंटर किया डेमो लिखा
इस एंटर किया देन मैं कंडीशन चेक करता हूं
ओपन ब्रैकेट देन हाइन एक्स यह हान एक्स की
बात कर रहा हूं उसके बाद मैंने लिखा यहां
पर डेमो देन उसके बाद क्लोज ब्रैकेट सेमी
कलन एक को किया और डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क
डॉलर क्वेश्चन मार्क टटर अभी ये क्या कर
रहा है जीरो दिखा रहा
है जीरो शो कर रहा है फाइल तो एजिस्ट करती
है बट
एग्जीक्यूशन
परमिशन आई थिंक प्रॉब्लम वेरी बिग
प्रॉब्लम ऑफ दिस ज सेल तो मैं क्या करता
हूं अभी अगर मैं एल करके दिखा आपको
देखो नो एग्जीक्यूटेबल परमिशन बट द
प्रॉब्लम ऑफ
ए जल इट्स ओके हम क्या कर देते हैं
ननो उसके बाद क्या करता हूं और एक और सक्ड
एसस को ओपन कर लेते हैं फाइल है अब इसको
मैं क्या करता ब्रेक कर बंद कर देता हूं
ये रहा ये रहा ये रहा है इसको क्लोज कर
देते हैं देन ये रहा हिट एंटर ये रहा अभी
मैं इसके अंदर एक कंडीशन लिखता हूं
कि ये ओपन ब्रैकेट देन उसके बाद हाइन एक्स
उसके बाद मैं चेक करना चाहता हूं कि जो
मेरे डेमो है डेमो फाइल है किसके
अंदर कमांड प्रोमट है
के नहीं ऐसे नहीं दे सकता मैं
इसको
[संगीत]
वेरिएबल के अंदर मुझे देना होगा वेरिएबल
के अंदर देना होगा वार
इक्वल वार
इक्वल लर कल बस इसके
बाद यह बैकटिक्स का यज करता बक यूज करता
हूं उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं एक कंडीशन
देता हूं देन उसके बाद हान एक्स उसके बाद
मैं चेक करता हूं डेमो
और बट क्या कहां पर चेक करेगा देखन करेगा
उस इट विल टेक टाइम देन य इसको सेव कर
लिया उसके बाद क्लोज कर देता इसी के साथ
डेमो उसके बाद इसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
को को करता इसका आउटपुट जो आएगा इसका
आउटपुट
करता
डॉलर क्वे मार्क
डलर क्वेश्चन मार्क तो बाद में देख लेंगे
क् मा बिल्कुल विल ा समथिंग ट बट आई ड नोट
विल वर्क और
नॉट अभी भी जीरो शो कर रहा है आ डोंट नो
ट बट य क्या करता है
इसका एट परमिशन चेक करने के लिए अगर मुझे
इस परमिशन दे भी देता हूं तो क्या
यह चेक करेगा वर्किंग न न आई डोंट
नो हा बट य ऐसे ही काम करता है एक्स
बेसिकली फाइल एस्ट करता मेरे केस में आ
डों नो की कुछ ग्लिच है इस मशीन के अंदर
तो प्रॉब्लम इधर आ रही है अगर एक और चीज
होती है हान ड अगर हान डब् य करते तो य
चेक करते फाइल इ राइटेल और नॉट राइबल अगर
मैं क्या करता हूं यह रहा इधर इसकी जगह य
रहा यहां पर अगर हान डब् यूज करो तो य चेक
करेगा कि फाइल राइबल है या नहीं इधर अभी
मतलब य राइबल है आई डोंट नो हर चीज को
जीरो ही क्यों ट्रो कर रहा है उसके बाद
हान
ल तो है तो इस तरीके से आप बहुत सारे पशन
का यज कर सकते आपको अगर एक बार लिस्ट बता
देता हूं खास करके इसके केस में यहा इसी
के केस में अगर मैं आपको टटर करता हूं देन
यह स्पेशल फोर फाइल चेक करने के लिए
बेसिकली स्पेशली फर हम चेक करने के लिए
क्या अगर मैं बताता आपको कौन कन से ऑप्शन
थे गव गव मी गव मी मिनट
यस मैंने एक तो हाइफ ई का यूज किया आईन ई
क्या करता है
आईन टू
कन्फर्म
फाइल एजिस्ट और नोट फल एजिस्ट और नोट और
उसके बाद हाइन उसके बाद हम यूज करते हाइन
एफ क्या करता है ये की
चेक्स
चेक्स चेक्स
इफ
समथिंग इज
ए रेगुलर
फाइल फइल
लाइक लाइक टेक्स्ट
फाइल टेक्स्ट फाइल या वर्ड फाइल वर्ड
वर्ड फाइल या पीडीएफ फाइल पीडीएफ फाइल ए य
चेक करता है देन हाइन अगर मैं डी यूज करता
हूं चक करता है
चेक
इट्स
इट्स डायरेक्टरी और
नॉट डी आई
आर सी डायरेक्टरी और नॉट
डायरेक्टरी और नोट य चेक करता है उसके बाद
मैंने हाइन एक्स दिखाया आपको काफी यूजफुल
मेरे केस में पता नहीं कैसे काम नहीं किया
आईन एक्स जो यूज करते हैं वह चेक करता है
कि फाइल
इज
एग्जीक्यूटेबल और
नॉट देन हाइन अगर आर करते
हैं फाइल
इज रीडेबल और नॉट
देन हाइन अगर यूज करते हम हान डब्लू करते
हैं तो फाइल
इज राइ टेबल और नॉट राइ टेबल और नॉट यह
चेक करता है फल राइबल और नॉट यह सब चेक
करता ीन सामने देखने को मिल रहा
होगा कन्फर्म फाइल एस्ट नो चेक समथि रेग
एक्स डाय चेक करने के लिए एटक ड चेक करने
के लिए चेक्स है जो आप इसके लिए लॉजिक के
अंदर आप यूज कर सकते हैं तो ये था आपका
लॉजिक सेक्शन टेस्ट कमांड
का अब बात करते हैं हम नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक्स
है हम बढ़ते हैं इसी में तो आज इधर ही एंड
करते हैं तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम पढ़ेंगे
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक जो वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग है इफ
कमांड के बारे में पढ़ेंगे कि इफ कमांड
कैसे काम करती है
और इ इफ एलिफ कैसे करता है काम में इफ और
एल्स कैसे काम काम करता है और अगर टाइम
रहा तो उसमें नेक्स्ट जो एक और कमांड
रहेगी जो लॉजिक सेक्शन की है जो केस कमांड
है वो भी हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं और उनके
बेस एक छोटे से असाइनमेंट ए असाइनमेंट
उसको करने वाले हैं तो मैं सबसे पहले आपको
एक चीज दिखा देता हूं कि लास्ट क्लास में
मैंने एक असाइनमेंट दिया था उसका सलूशन
आपको शो कर देता हूं यह रहा असाइनमेंट
क्या था आपको ये देखने को मिल रहा होगा यह
रहा असाइनमेंट ये रहा असाइनमेंट में आपको
करना क्या था बेसिकली छोटा सा काम करना था
वो आप लोगों मुझे लगता नहीं कि किया होगा
इट्स ओके तो मैं आपको शो कर देता हूं कि
यह किस तरीके से आपको करना था किस तरीके
से करना था किस तरीके से नहीं करना इसका
सलूशन क्या होगा इसने क्या बोला है यू आर
सेटिंग अप ए न्यू स्विच स्विच बोर्ड फॉर र
क जूम कर लेता हूं यू आर सेटिंग अप ए न्यू
स्विच बोर्ड फॉर योर कंपनी फोन सिस्टम
मतलब क्या कर र हो कि आपकी कंपनी है कंपनी
में आप क्या कर रहे हो कोई एक नया स्विच
बोर्ड लगवा रहे हो टेलीफोन सिस्टम का कुछ
भी कनि परपस के
लिए यू नीड टू कलेक्ट एवरीवनस करंट
एक्सटेंशन नंबर एंड द पिन कोड ट दे वांट
टू यूज वन मेकिंग कॉल्स बेसिकली आप उसके
बाद आपको क्या एक टास्क दिया गया है कि
आपको क्या करना है कि उनका करंट जो
एक्सटेंशन नंबर है प्लस में जो पिन कोड है
काल कॉल करने के लिए वह आपको कलेक्शन करना
है बिकॉज देर इज नो इंटरनल फोन यू डिसाइड
टू राइट ए बेस्ट स्क्रिप्ट टू रिक्वेस्ट
दिस इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम ईच ऑफ योर लिग एंड
राइट इट टू ए सीएसवी फाइल टू प्रोसेस लेटर
अभी क्या है कि देखो आप इस एक काम करो कि
आपको ये टास्क दिया तो आप बैठे-बैठे क्या
करोगे सबके पास घूमो क्या वो काम करने के
लिए सिंपली आपने डिसाइड किया कि मैं एक
बेस स्क्रिप्ट बना देता हूं वो सभी उसको
रन करेंगे अपनी डिटेल फिल करेंगे उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट पास कर देंगे सब करेंगे और ये
क्या करेगा आपका क्लिक के लिए है बेसिकली
सब के लिए है और उसके अंदर उसका जो आउटपुट
ऑटोमेटिक कहीं पर जाके फाइल के अंदर सेव
सेव हो जाएगा और जिससे आपका काम बहुत ही आ
आसान हो जाएगा तो सबसे पहला काम आपको क्या
करना है कि फर्स्टली यू कैन क्रिएट
स्क्रिप्ट कॉल्ड इंफो कलेक्शन आपको मैंने
काफी हिंट के साथ दिया है कि सबसे पहले
आपको क्या है स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करनी है
जिसका नाम इंफो कलेक्शन है इन दिस
स्क्रिप्ट यू विल नीड टू आस्क योर यूजर
फॉर पीस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन यूजिंग रीड कमांड
अब मैंने यहां पर हिंट भी दिया कि आपको
रीड कमांड का यूज करना है और आपको ये चार
पीस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन कि व्हाट इज योर फर्स्ट
नेम व्हाट इज योर नेम या फैमिली नेम व्ट्स
योर एक्सटेंशन नंबर और व्ट एक्सेस कोड वुड
यू लाइक टू यूज वाइल डायलिंग इन कौन सा
एक्सेस कोड आप पसंद करोगे यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या करना आप अपने यूजर से
चाहिए बट आपको रीड कमांड इसलिए यूज करनी
पड़े ताक यूजर को अच्छा लगे मुझे किस टाइप
की इंफॉर्मेशन इसके अंदर फिल करनी है तो
यू मस्ट एडवाइज द यूजर ट देयर एक्सटेंशन
नंबर एंड एक्सेस कोड मस्ट बोथ बी एटली फ ल
मतलब आपके यहां पर कंडीशन यह है कि आपको
जो एक्सटेंशन नंबर रहेगा जो एक्सेस कोड है
वो चा डिजिट से लंबा नहीं होना चाहिए अब
भैया आपने तो कंडीशन लगा दी अब सभी यूजर
एक जैसे अच्छे तो इंसान नहीं होते सोचे कि
मैं तो ट्राई करूंगा पाच डिजिट डालने की
तो आपको यह भी देखना कि मुझे उसको
रिस्ट्रिक्टर कि मुझे चार डिजिट ही लंग
चाहिए यू शुड इंश्योर दैट द एक्सटेंशन एंड
पिन नंबर आर एगजैक्टली फोर डिजिट लॉन्ग
फोर डिजिट आपको ये इंश्योर आपका काम है
स्क्रिप्ट ऐसे बनानी है आपको हिंट भी दे
देता हूं व्हेन एंटरिंग प्राइवेट
इंफॉर्मेशन लाइक एक्सेस कोड जब आप
प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन एक्सेस कोड जैसे
प्राइवेट इंफॉर्मेशन जब आप क्या करोगे
एंटर कर रहे होगे तो इट इज ऑलवेज बेटर टू
प्रिवेंट व्ट द यूजर टाइप्स फ्रॉम
अपीयरिंग इन द टर्मिनल तो वो यूजर को
दिखनी चाहिए नॉर्मल जब पासवर्ड डायल करते
हु आपको पासवर्ड तो नहीं दिखता हु डॉट डॉट
डॉट डॉट आपको ऐसे करना है स्टेप आपका दो
टू था क्या था यू देन नीड टू सेव दिस
इंफॉर्मेशन टू ए फाइल कॉल्ड इनफर्मेशन ड
सीएसवी एक इंफॉर्मेशन
सीएसवी है इसके अंदर आपको फाइल को सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन शेव करनी है सभी क्लाइंट के
सभी क्लिक्स की इन द फॉलोइंग फॉर्मेट
फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम एक्सटेंशन एक्सेस इस
तरीके से होनी चाहिए और मेक श्यर करना कि
व सारी की सारी जो इंफॉर्मेशन आपके जो
कलीग्स है जो इसके अंदर जो रन कर कर के
फीड करेंगे वो सारी इसी फाइल के अंदर सेव
हो तो आपको एक छोटा सा टास्क करना था यह
आपका जो टास्क था तो मैं इसका क्या कर
आपको कैसे सॉल्व करना था मैं आपको बताता
हूं सिंपली सी इस असाइनमेंट को तो इसको
मुझे सॉल्व करना है इसके बेस मुझे ब
स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी है तो लिख दूंगा नो इशू
तो मैं क्लियर करता हूं स्क्रीन को एक बार
मैं एस करता हं फालतू की चीज स्क्रीन पर
क्या है
रिमूव टू वाली चीज रिमूव कर देता हूं आई
आरम कर देता हूं फाइल उसके
बाद ओके फाइल के बाद ल यह कर द मैंने एलस
करता हूं देन य सा चली डेली फीडबैक वाली य
भी रिमूव कर देता हूं फालतू की चीज रिमूव
करने वाला
य भी रिमूव कर देता हूं उसके
बाद मंथली यह भी कर रहा हूं उसके
बाद डे डॉटी एक्सटी देन उसके बाद क्या है
यस ओके सेलेक्ट ड्रिप
सारी देखते हैं बाद में एलस जन अब मैं
क्या करता हूं मैं नो किया एन ए एन ओ ननो
उसके बाद अबकी बार में प्रोजेक्ट का नाम
है आपको मैंने बताया था क्या प्रोजेक्ट का
प्रोजेक्ट का जो मेरा अरे व्ट इ द इ ब्रो
य रहा प्रोजेक्ट का नाम था इंफो कलेक्शन
प्रोजेक्ट मेरा नाम था इंफो कलेक्शन इंफो
उसके बाद कलेक्शन प्रोजेक्ट का नाम मेरा
इंफो कलेक्शन है डॉट एस कर देता हूं
एक्सटेंशन के साथ ओके फर्स्ट लाइन में आप
क्या करोगे ये सी बैंक पार्ट आपका सी बैंक
पार्ट स्ल बिन और बस सिंपली बस उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना
है चार पीस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन
अपने यूजर से लेनी है फर पीसे इंफॉर्मेशन
लेनी है कौन-कौन सी ये रही कि आपका फर्स्ट
नेम क्या है सरनेम क्या है एक्सटेंशन नंबर
और एक्सेस कोड और एक्सेस कोड को क्या करना
है आपको हाइड करना है मतलब दिखे ना चलो ये
भी हम कर देंगे कैसे करेंगे ये रहा चलो तो
मैं सबसे पहले रीड कमांड यूज करूंगा तो
रीड किया मैंने उसके बाद हाइन प हाइन प का
मतलब आपको प्रोमट करना है उसके बाद प्रोमट
करने के लिए आपको उसके बाद यह करना है कि
व्हाट इज
व्ट इज
योर
फर्स्ट नेम व्ट इज योर फर्स्ट नेम क्वेन
मार्क देन उसके
बाद कॉलन स्पेस कर दिया देन उसके बाद एक
वेरिएबल के अंदर सेव करना ल सेव करने के
लिए मैंने लिखा इसके फर्स्ट वेरिएबल का
नाम सिंपली नेक्स्ट लाइन पर क्या कर रीड
करना है देन हान प उसके प्रोमट करना है
देन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है य व्ट इज
योर लास्ट नेम सिंपली व्ट इज योर लास्ट
नेम देन सिंपली इसको क्लोज कर देना है
इसको लास्ट नेम नाम से वेरिएबल में इसकी
वैल्यू सेव हो जानी थ उसके बाद रीड उसके
बाद
हाइन प तो मैंने यूज किया एक और ऑप्शन
होता है भैया हाइन एन आन ए यूज करता हूं
देन उसके बाद मैं लिखता हूं फोर मुझे क्या
करना है लिमिट लगाने की फोर डिजिट ही मुझे
मस्ट है फोर डिजिट ही होना चाहिए फोर
डिजिट से ज्यादा नहीं होना चाहिए फिर भी
कुछ लोग ट्राई करते हैं तो यहां पर मैंने
इसकी वजह से क्या फोर डिजिट ही यहां पर
आपको वैल्यू मिलेगी इससे ज्यादा यह स्टोर
ही नहीं करेगा तो देखो अब ये इसके बाद हान
ए देन उसके बाद में क्या हान कैपिटल ए आई
थिंक मुझे लगता है कैपिटल एन हापन कैपिटल
ए उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं यहां
पर व्ट इज योर
करंट आर ई एनटी करंट य
एक्सटेंशन करंट
एक्सटेंशन नंबर करंट एक्सटेंशन व्ट इ र
करंट एक्सटेंशन नंबर देन उसके बाद ब्रैकेट
में उसको हिंट भी दे देता हूं ताकि पता
चले
के मस्ट बी फोर डिजिट मस्ट बी
फोर मस्ट बी फोर डिजिट होना चाहिए ऐसा
नहीं कुछ भी न टूथ व्ट एवर देन उसके बाद
ये उसके बाद इसकी वैल्यू किसके अंदर स्टोर
करना चाहते वेरिएबल के अंदर इसके ता
एक्सटेंशन एक्सटेंशन एक्सटी एक्सटेंशन के
नाम से करना चा देन उसके बाद फिर से मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं रीड कर रहा हूं देन
हान उसके बाद ए तो इसम रखूंगा ही हान प भी
रखूंगा उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं यह
रहा नेक्स्ट
ट
एक्सेस कोड व्ट एक्सेस
कोड वुड यू लाइक टू यूज अब कौन सा एक्सेस
कोड यूज करना चाहते होय काफी
कॉन्फिडेंशियल है कॉन्फिडेंशियल है भैया
ली है कि एक्सेस कोड ऐसे तो ना पता कर
लोगे य क्या बोला मस्ट बी फोर डिजिट अब
क्या आईजी आईडी मस्ट बी फोर डिजिट होना
चाहिए भैया ऐसा नहीं है कुछ भी य कर लोगे
देन य उसके बाद इसको वल किसके एक्सेस के
अंदर अभी बात करते हैं ये क्या होना चाहिए
आपका हाइड में आना चाहिए हाइड करने के लिए
आप यूज करोगे एक ऑप्शन होता है हाइन एस
सीक्रेट हाइफ एस का मतलब सीक्रेट है ये
आपको क्या है डॉट में दिखाया आपको स्क्रीन
पे जब टाइप करोगे तो आपको देखने को ना
मिले ताकि कोई पीछे से आपको शोल्डर
सर्फिंग भी कर रहा होगा तो आपको प्रॉब्लम
ना हो भले ही करता रहे शोल्डर सर्फिंग
वैसे तो देख पाया की बेड से बट ऐसे पॉसिबल
नहीं होगा ना अब बात करते हैं हम कि अभी
इसको मुझे सेव करना फाइल के अंदर सेव करने
के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं एक अभी देन यह
रहा उसके बाद
डॉलर फाइल नेम फाइल नेम उसके बाद कॉमा
डॉलर लास्ट अरे लास्ट नेम फाइल नेम नहीं
फर्स्ट नेम था
मेरा फर्स्ट नेम उसके बाद लास्ट नेम देन
उसके बाद है मेरा ये ड
एक्सटी उसके बाद कॉमा डॉलर य मेरा
एक्सेस एक्सेस उसके बाद इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन
को क्या करना चाहता हूं हर बार अपेंड करना
चाहता
हूं डबल डायरेक्शन सिंबल क्योंकि अपेंड
करना चाहता हूं इसलिए फाइल का नाम क्या है
मेरा फाइल का नाम मेरा रहेगा र देखो तो
आपको इनफर्मेशन ड सीएसवी इनफर्मेशन डट इन
फॉर्मेशन डॉट सीएसवी वैसे तो सीएसवी फाइल
बनेगी नहीं
सी एसवी बट हमें क्या है वैसे रख रहे हैं
हम अपने लिए इनफर्मेशन डट सीएसवी
इनफॉर्म इनफर्मेशन ड सीएसवी ट उसके बाद
मैं क्या करता ह
इसको कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल एक्स उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं इस फाइल को परमिशन देंगे
सीच मोड परमिशन अबके बाद में 7 55 दूंगा
क्योंकि मुझे अभी क्लिक्स के साथ शयर करना
है वो सिर्फ क्या करना है एग्जीक्यूट ना
कर पाए एक्यूट
लेकिन रीड कर पाए एी क्यूट कर पाए लेकिन
मॉडिफाई ना कर पाए इसलिए परमिशन दे रहा
हूं उसके बाद क्या इंफो एच परमिशन मैंने
मेंशन कर दिया एलस हान एल करके देखोगे तो
आपको देखने को मिल इस
परमिशन कौन सी है फाइल इंफो
इंफो इंफो य इंफो कलेक्शन यह रहा देन उसके
बाद मैं क्या करता हूं आपको रन कर दिखा
देता फाइल को डॉट इनो य रहा र व्हाट योर
फर्स्ट नेम मैंने लिखा सचिन योर लास्ट नेम
मैंने यह लिख दिया
सचिन सी एच आई एन सचिन
देन
फाइव वैलिड आइडेंटिफिकेशन
आई
थ आन
प और इसको य
भी
व एस सीक्रेट के लिए स्मल एस यूज करते
हम स्मल एस होगा आई
थिंक लेटस सी आ सीक्रेट के लिए यूज करते
हैं नहीं तो हम हेल्प फाइल देख लेंगे उसके
बाद कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स रन करते हैं
फो कलेक्शन ए ए सचिन बाद एस ए सी
सचिन स चिन देन ओके फोर डिजिट कुछ भी आपको
क्या लिखना है व्ट इज योर करंट एक्सटेंशन
नंबर मैंने लिखा टूथ 4 व्ट इज योर एक्सेस
कोड एक्सेस कोड लि 6789 कर दिया देखो अभी
यह था इसने अभी क्या थोड़ा गुड लुकिंग
नहीं है कोड लग रहा है अब मैं इसको एलस
करता हूं देखो इधर एक फाइल इमेशन सीएसवी
कैट करता हूं तो इमे इनफर्मेशन ड सीएसवी
इनफर्मेशन
डट
इनफर इ इसके अंदर सचिन सचिन य देखो इस
तरीके से इस सेव हो पहले तो गलत हुआ उसके
सेकंड टाइम में ऐसे सेव हो गया तो थोड़ा
सा गड़बड़ हुआ य मैं इसको क्या करता एक
बार इस फाइल को एक बार रिमूव कर देता हूं
और इंफॉर्मेशन क हर बार अपेंड होगा इसके
अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन
डॉट इनफर्मेशन ड सीएसवी हिट एंटर उसके बाद
मैं क्या करता हूं न करता हूं वापस जाता
हूं थोड़ा सा बहतर तरीके से इसको दिखाता
हूं ये रहा अभी क्या करना अच्छा दिखे मैं
यहां पर क्या करता हूं को मेंशन कर देता
हूं यहां पर एक उसके क्योंकि को मेंशन
किया मतलब एक ब्लैक लाइन आ जाएगी देन उसके
बाद फिर मैं क्या मेंशन करता हूं
एकको ब्लैंक लाइन आ जाएगी देन मुझे लगता
है कि अभी जो मेरा आउटपुट है वो बेहतरीन
दिखना चाहिए मेरा जो आउटपुट है वो काफी
अच्छा शो होना चाहिए देरा ये रहा
एकको कंट्रोल एस एक्स उसके बाद ये रहा
इसको मैं रन करके दिखाता हूं अभी अच्छे
तरीके से य रहा अभी मैं लिखता हूं जैसे
नितेश एन आई टी ई एस एच नितेश उसके बाद एस
आई एनजी सि उसका नंबर मैं उनका लिखा मैंने
व्ट इ र करंट एक्सटेंशन नंबर तो फोर डिजिट
होना चाहिए 789 जी उसके बाद ऑटोमेटिक फोर
के बाद कट हो रहा है फोर के बाद नेक्स्ट
लाइन पर जा रहा है फोर से ज्यादा ले नहीं
रहा उसके बाद मैं लिख रहा हूं मैं टूथ फर
सिंपली देखो इजी है और अगर आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन कैट करके देखोगे इनम सीएसवी
टटर देखो निते सिं 7890 23 4 आपको इस
तरीके से आपको दि और यहां पर देखो आप कुछ
भी नहीं दिखा क्योंकि आपने यहां पर
सीक्रेट यूज किया हु है तो ट्स ऑल यह था
आपकी जो उसका जो आंसर था यह था आपका वो
कोड लिखना था छोटा सा कोड लिखना से ज्यादा
कोई कोड लिखना नहीं था उस असाइनमेंट का आस
ये था तो मैंने इस असाइनमेंट का भी
सोल्यूशन आपको प्रोवाइड कर दिया है तो इस
तरीके से क्या है कि छोटी-छोटी चीजों को
जब आप सीखते रहोगे खुद से ट्राई करोगे
मुझे क्या करना है क्योंकि पूरी हिंट के
साथ ये असाइनमेंट है ऐसा भी नहीं कि ऐसा
ही है देखो पूरी हिंट के साथ ये असाइनमेंट
है बस आपको पढ़ना था समझना था और मैंने
बताया कि रीड कमांड का यूज करना है जो
कांसेप्ट मैंने बताया उस कांसेप्ट के
बेसिस को के बेसिस पर आपको इस असाइनमेंट
को कंप्लीट करना था इस असाइनमेंट को बहुत
इजी असाइनमेंट इस तरीके से अगर आप
छोटे-छोटे क्या है बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक सीखो ना
तभी आप क्या बड़ी बिल्डिंग बना पाओ आओगे
तो ट्स नाउ
तो आज थोड़ी लंबी क्लास रही बट आई होप की
इंटरेस्टिंग क्लास रही होगी
तो सेशन को एंड करते हैं तो स्टिल हैव एनी
डाउट तो प्लीज आस्क मी नाउ आई एम फॉर
नेक्स्ट ट
मिनट एनी डाउट लेट टू द कंसेप्ट टुडे
कांसेप्ट या लास्ट डे 13 1 क्लासेस
कांसेप्ट ट एनी डाउट्स यू कैन आस्क मी
नाउ इफ नो डाउट सो सिंपली से नो तो देन आई
विल क्लोज द
सेशन
एक्चुअली मैं आपको दे सकता हूं बट नोबडी
विल इंटरेस्टेड कोई करता ही नहीं अभी
असमेंट य था इससे पहले मैंने एक असाइनमेंट
और दिया था अगर चाहो तो य ट्राई कर सकते
हो यह भी किसी ने किया नहीं
यहा नंबर ू य रहा यह भी किसी ने कि नहीं
यू कैन टेक द स्क्रीनशॉट मेक इट एंड सबमिट
इट या सेंड सेंड इन द
ग्रुप सीट यह रहा बिल्कुल हार्डली टू मिनट
इफ यू नो द कांसेप्ट इट विल टेक हार्डली
टू मिनट बट मुझे जो इसमें लिखा है ना उसी
बेसिस पर
चाहिए अगर आपको
इस उसी बेसिस पर क्योंकि यह कांसेप्ट है
इस कांसेप्ट को क्लियर करने के
लिए यह असाइनमेंट है यह किसके बेसिस पर है
आपका कैलकुलेटर स्क्रिप्ट आपका सेलेक्ट
कमांड के बेसिस सेलेक्ट नहीं है आपका मे
बी स्पेशल पैरामीटर के बेसिस प असाइनमेंट
है तो स्पेशल पैरामीटर का जब मैंने क्लास
करवाया था उसको समझाया था स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स क्या होते हैं और पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर्स का जो असाइनमेंट था ये रहा ये
मैंने सॉल्व कर दिया था ये स्पेशल
पैरामीटर है और एक ही असाइनमेंट था
असाइनमेंट नंबर ऑन पोजीशन पैरामीटर ये
मैंने सॉल्व कर दिया था डे 13 की जो क्लास
थी उसमें स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स को मैंने
पढ़ाया था और स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स में डे 13
क्लास था आई थिंक आई रिमेंबर डे क्ला
स्पेशल पैरामीटर मैंने आपको पढ़ाया था और
यह रहा आपको रिफ्लेक्टिंग बैक जो भी है यह
यह आपको असमेंट दिया था तो यह असाइनमेंट
आप
कीजिए ग्रुप में सेंड कर दीजिए मेरे को
डबल मेहनत आप करवा रहे हो बट वई न टेकिंग
द
स्क्रीनशॉट इफ यू हैव द मोबाइल या एनी
डिवाइस यू कैन टेक इली स्क्रीनशॉट एंड सॉट
एंड सेंड द आंसर इन द
ग्रुप व्हाट एवर इफ यू आर कंफर्टेबल इन
फाइल तो देन सेंड मी विद फाइल अदर वाइज यू
कैन आल्सो सेंड द स्क्रीनशॉट ऑफ द योर
कोड लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ देम अटेंड दिस
असाइनमेंट नंबर टू बिकॉज आई विल टिल नाउ
आई विल नॉट प्रोवाइड द सॉल्यूशन ऑफ दिस
असाइनमेंट नंबर टू आई विल सॉल्व द सेन
नंबर नंबर
थ्री टुडे तो इट्स ओके
तो सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
सेशन तो बाय बाय गुड डे गुड नाइट व्ट एवर
बाय
कर